[Music]
on this tuesday night a spike in cases
of covet variants how and where they are
spreading
as canada squeezes more vaccine doses
out of pfizer biontech vials
we get a bit more vaccine than we
expected plus the new rules at land
borders
and small businesses becoming zombie
businesses
it hurts the struggle to stay afloat
during the pandemic
trump on trial the second impeachment
proceeding for the former u.s
president plus deep freeze this is
ridiculous cold
the brutally cold weather blowing
through western canada
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with news about the highly
contagious new variants of covid19
they continue to spread as some
provinces begin easing restrictions
canada's top doctor said today the
number of confirmed cases of the new
variants in canada
has more than doubled in the last week
381 cases have now been detected
in eight provinces since genomic
sequencing is needed to confirm the
variance it's likely
more cases exist and in three provinces
there is now evidence the variants
aren't just related to travel but are
spreading
through the community that could quickly
lead to a resurgence in cases the
federal government is putting tighter
controls on people crossing the border
starting next monday february 15th
non-essential travelers coming into
canada by land
will be required to show a negative
covid19 test done
within the last 72 hours canadians who
try to return without a test
cannot legally be stopped from entering
but they could face fines
of up to three thousand dollars changes
are also being made to canada's rollout
of the pfizer bayern tech vaccine
health canada has approved a request to
extract
six doses out of each vial instead of
five
that means fewer vials could be shipped
in the weeks ahead
abigail beeman has tonight's top story
on the change
and why at least one province isn't
happy about it
next week marks the start of a major
ramp up
in vaccine shipments the pfizer biontech
vaccine will now go further health
canada approved a label change to show
six doses per vial instead of five we
expect to receive and distribute
approximately four hundred
000 doses next week and 475 doses in the
last week of february
special low dead space syringes are
needed the government ordered 64 million
and the first ones are now being shipped
to provinces
the company has come in and has
demonstrated through their studies
is that if you're using those syringes
reliably
using the technique the good techniques
um in terms of
and drawing up the dose and
administering them that you should be
able to get that six dose reliably
alberta disagrees it is frustrating i
think we made it clear
to the um to the federal government and
to health canada that uh
you know everybody gets the best
training everybody get is using the
the um the right syringe we're only
going to get that sixth dose
75 percent of the time max other
provinces are pleased
we get a bit more vaccine than we
expected but it helps make up for the
vaccine
reductions that we've had in the last
few weeks we are
working to get the exact
perfect needle as part of the deal the
company must provide educational support
to provinces and send health canada any
complaints quarterly
and the steady call for more vaccines
comes against the backdrop of new
variant cases
any of the cases that might be
associated with individuals having
received a vaccine dose i think would be
something else we'd be looking at if the
vaccines have impact on her the immunity
it may mean that more proportions of the
population have to be
vaccinated in order for that to be
achieved canada's top
doctor says provinces must be extremely
cautious about reopening dr
tam is worried if cases spike again due
to variance it would be much more
difficult to control
meanwhile we still don't know how many
moderna doses we're getting in the next
shipment two weeks from now
we just know it will be less than
originally expected
abigail beeman global news ottawa
one province that had kept coveted
numbers low is now dealing with a
worrying surge
newfoundland and labrador reported 30
new cases of covid19 today the biggest
single day increase since march of 2020.
public health restrictions have been put
in place in saint john's
as ross lord reports this is happening
the week of a provincial election
in newfoundland and labrador holding an
election in the middle of winter is
risky
pulling it off during a growing covet 19
outbreak could be
even more challenging we have 30 new
cases of kovid 19 in our province
all are in eastern health region health
officials say there's community
transmission
that's a big deal in a small province
where covet 19 had been stifled since
last spring
we are therefore implementing a two-week
circuit breaker to slow the spread of
the virus
that means a range of businesses
including bars fitness centers and
cinemas
will be closed this is probably the
worst case scenario you know in terms of
community spread
the outbreak is traced to a local
restaurant and to a high school
both in mount pearl outside st john's
the main emotion you're feeling is
anxiety right because everybody
you know as we started this week was
really wondering you know whose impact
and who wasn't
about a thousand students and staff are
being tested
among those crossing their fingers hard
is premier andrew fury
he chose to call an election now instead
of waiting until later in the year
with covid cases climbing fury is
getting blasted online
he insists he has no regrets we were
going to
do have to deal with covid related
issues in an election cycle
is it ideal no but i didn't create that
scenario i was
making a judgment at the time based on
the numbers and looking at the
trying to look into the future as best i
could fury says it's up to election
officials to decide if it's necessary to
delay
saturday's vote he suggests he's
confident it can be conducted safely
while admitting no one knows how large
the outbreak could be
by then ross lord global news
another major round of cuts is coming to
canada's largest airline
air canada is laying off at least 1500
more employees and starting next week
17 routes to the u.s and overseas will
be suspended until at least
april 30th thousands of canadians who
were told they would have to repay
federal emergency benefits are getting a
reprieve self-employed residents who
applied for the canada emergency
response benefit based on their gross
income
instead of their net won't have to pay
the benefit back
upwards of 400 000 people received
letters from the cra last year
suggesting
they may not be eligible for the serb
the state of emergency in ontario
expires today as parts of that province
begin to gradually reopen
for some businesses it could be too late
though the canadian federation of
independent business reports
sixty thousand of its members have shut
down it warns that number could rise if
the federal government
doesn't revamp its support programs mike
trolley has the story of one business
owner
feeling the squeeze
it was only a year ago aaron martin was
having a hard time keeping up with
demand for the craft beers he makes
at kingston's riverhead brewery this new
reality where sales are now measured in
drips
it's hard for him to swallow so yeah you
know we're selling but all our margins
are getting squeezed
squeezed everywhere and you know it
hurts
like every other business during the
pandemic he's had to adapt
he once had 15 employees now he has
three
and while he used to be brewmaster he's
now also canning and doing deliveries
all the while trying to make sense of
government programs that are barely
keeping them afloat
i mean they treated everyone equal but
they didn't treat everyone
equitable is is kind of the problem
right
we're in your corner last spring the
federal government rushed to introduce
relief measures but 10 months later
critics argue any shortcomings
should have been corrected new
businesses for example such as the
three-year-old riverhead brewery
don't have the financial history to
accurately show losses
and either aren't getting enough support
or don't qualify at all
business owners are tired of hearing
politicians say that we've got your back
that's true for some but it's it's an
incomplete message at the best
economists point out that bankruptcies
were down in 2020
suggesting government programs are
indeed keeping businesses afloat
but craig alexander warns that will end
quickly if critical issues like debt
forgiveness aren't addressed
when the government programs are
eventually wound down
we're going to start to actually see the
true economic scars
a ministry of finance spokesperson says
they're doing everything they can to
avoid that
and as part of their pre-budget
consultations they're asking canadians
to share their ideas
mike delay global news kingston ontario
in the u.s the daily case count of
covid19 infections has dipped below 100
000 for the past
two days in a row it hasn't been that
low since before the november election
in washington the focus is on the senate
impeachment trial of former president
donald trump
the case against him that he incited a
mob to storm the capitol was laid out
today
jackson proskow is following the trial
for us
with the capital still fortified by
fences and razor wire
the article of impeachment against
donald john trump
the senate got to work on an historic
post-presidential impeachment
the gravest charges ever brought against
a president
of the united states in american history
republicans don't want to hear it they
hated the results of the 2016 election
and want to use this impeachment process
to further their political agenda
echoing trump's defense that the process
is both unconstitutional
and pointless now that he's out of
office i think this thing is not going
anywhere
i think it is a terrible terrible waste
of time
democrats argue there can't be an
exception for trump's conduct in his
final days
even if that means impeaching a former
president
to make their case democrats presented a
harrowing video of the moments
lawmakers lived through showing how
trump's words played into that grim day
that's a high crime and misdemeanor if
that's not an impeachable offense
then there is no such thing the coming
days will focus on a single article of
impeachment for incitement of
insurrection
democrats will argue it was a moment
months in the making
that should disqualify trump from
holding future office
this is a case where they're trying to
steal an election they're trying to
rig an election trump's defense wants to
focus strictly on the events of january
6th
you'll never take back our country with
weakness
in a 75-page rebuttal trump's legal team
argued his use of the word fight on
january
6th was in the figurative sense that has
long been accepted in public discourse
they plan to claim the storming of the
capital was pre-planned by
rioters not incited by the president
it's difficult to say that now that the
people who've been
charged with the insurrection are now
saying that he told us to do it
so who do you believe
who do you believe jackson what is the
timeline for this when is the senate
trial likely to wrap up well donna with
the senate voting that the trial itself
is in fact constitutional they'll start
the formal hearing tomorrow but this
could be done within a week
that's because of course there are no
witnesses being called but that also
likely doesn't change the outcome with
republicans unlikely to turn on trump at
this point
meaning it's unlikely they'll have the
two-thirds needed to convict him in the
senate
all right jackson proskow in washington
thanks
the house of commons defense committee
here in canada has unanimously agreed to
conduct a study into allegations of
inappropriate behavior
by canada's former top soldier general
jonathan vance
this is over and above a military police
investigation into allegations
vance had an ongoing relationship with a
woman he significantly outranked
today prime minister justin trudeau was
asked about what he knew
about the allegations of inappropriate
behavior towards
female subordinates i think knees just
want to know what you knew first of all
canadians know that everyone whether
they're in the armed forces
or working for the canadian government
or in any workplace across the country
deserves to be in a safe workplace free
from harassment or
or unacceptable actions
sources have told global news that in
2018 the military ombudsman raised
concerns with defense minister harjit
sajjan about alleged sexual misconduct
by general vance who knew what when was
the subject
of a parliamentary committee meeting
this afternoon sagin will be called to
testify
before the national defense committee
and alberta premier jason kenney has
also been invited
because he was defense minister when
vance was appointed as chief of the
defense staff
vance has denied all allegations of
inappropriate behavior
from revoking a policy to reinstating it
coming up
the alberta government's u-turn on coal
mining
there's been a big reversal on coal
mining development in alberta
after intense pressure the alberta
government has reinstated a policy it
quietly
revoked last year it protects parts of
the rockies from open pit coal mines
coal is by far canada's most abundant
fossil fuel and more than 90 percent of
canada's coal deposits
are located in western provinces bc has
10 mines alberta has nine mines
as eric sorensen reports the alberta
government can usually count on broad
public support for policies promoting
the fossil fuel industry
but not this time at a time when its oil
economy is down
alberta is increasing coal production
but it's been forced to reinstate a 1976
policy that protects parts of the rocky
mountains from coal mining
the decision to end that policy last
spring triggered a public backlash
including from some traditional
supporters like ranchers
we should have done better and we admit
that we didn't get this one right
the government says now sales of new
leases will be halted till
after public consultations but coal
exploration already granted approval
will continue
they clearly have an agenda an agenda
to jeopardize our air and our land
and our water nothing is coming easily
for premier jason kenny these days
this is a gut punch he already lost an
expensive gamble on the keystone
pipeline
and while he has vowed to fight on for
it canadians it seems have moved on
an ipsos survey found only 18 percent of
canadians want to press
washington to reverse the decision to
kill keystone xl
even in alberta just 21 percent want to
press on with it
we've had the keystone xl of course
which has been a disaster for the
province
this academic says whether it's oil or
coal this alberta government is living
in the past
they're stuck in some sort of
retroconservative
ideology that will not permit them
to look at alternatives still no
province faces a bigger challenge
adjusting to a world increasingly
turning away from fossil fuels
when it comes to coal the government
says it's learned its lesson from
albertans
they expect us to manage coal
differently we intend to balance
stringent environmental protections
and responsible resource development for
ranchers john smith and laura lange
living near the rockies there is
temporary relief
that new coal leases will be paused
we're encouraged right
but unfortunately a lot of trust has
been lost
the couple says efforts to limit coal
mining accomplished something you don't
see every day
it brought urban and rural albertans
together
eric sorenson global news
ahead the investigation into covid 19's
origins
austria is now restricting movement from
a popular winter tourist destination
because of new variant concerns the
government there has announced it will
require a negative coronavirus test from
anyone
leaving the alpine province of tyrol
nearly 300 cases of the more contagious
variant first detected in south africa
have been confirmed
in the region and britain is bringing in
tighter border controls that include
stiff penalties for those caught lying
about their
travel history the new measures will
require travelers arriving from 33
red list countries to quarantine in
hotels for 10 days
those who try to hide the information
could face up to 10 years in prison
and hefty fines the changes are in place
on monday a team of investigators led by
the world health organization is in
china investigating the origins of
covid19 and it says
it's extremely unlikely the novel
coronavirus originated in a lab in china
the investigators say they didn't find
anything to support what is widely
considered to be
a conspiracy theory all the work that
has been done
on the virus and trying to
identify its origin continue to point
towards
a natural reservoir of this
virus and similar viruses in bad
population
the team says it is still unclear how
the virus jumped from animals to humans
the seafood market where it was first
discovered in wuhan is still
the focus of the investigation including
whether frozen animal products sold at
the market
may have been a source of transmission
can you hear me judge i can hear you i
think it's a filter
can kittens practice law on zoom they
can
that's next
mary wilson a founding member of the
supremes has died
she and diana ross and florence ballard
formed the trio over six decades ago
when the others left wilson stayed and
sang on all 12 of the group's number one
hits
the supremes remain one of the most
successful female singing groups ever
wilson went on to produce two solo
albums author four
books and she competed on dancing with
the stars last year at the age
of 75. canada is facing a supreme
cold snap extreme cold warnings are in
effect from bc to manitoba
and with wind chills parts of alberta
feel like minus
55. robin gill looks at how people are
coping
don't be fooled by the glimpse of sun in
british columbia
it belies the minus one chill that is
making vancouver rights
shiver cold very cold
in alberta the game must go on at the
world's longest hockey tournament
despite the deep freeze in that province
we're all stiff and
trying to stay warm and putting beeswax
on our cheeks to keep the frost bite
away
the prairies are bearing the brunt of
the bone-chilling weather
it's numbing to look at the extreme
temperatures with the wind chill
temperatures are anywhere from 10 to 25
degrees below average for this time of
year which is traditionally
cold anyway but this is ridiculous cold
it's that arctic surge
and it looks like that's going to last
for several days the issue about wind
chill is
you know even if it's minus 20 when you
add the wind to it
it increases heat loss and cools your
skin down
faster to that dangerous temperature
that's why crews in winnipeg are keeping
a close eye
on the most vulnerable right now
everyone in the community is survival
mode
right so we make sure we're able to
provide them with those resources that
they're able to meet
same goes for the homeless in vancouver
where warming centers
are open warming centers are critical
and they're really a life-saving
initiative for people that are
experiencing homelessness and
don't have anywhere else to go if
there's any consolation in normally
bombing british columbia
there is a break coming we're going to
complain it's too hot soon enough so i'm
great with it
and at least in this part of canada they
can already smell the flowers blooming
and winter isn't even over robin gill
global news
vancouver that's global national for
this tuesday we've tossed out your
canada for tonight we'll bring it back
but we all laughed
so hard at this we had to show it to you
it's a zoom call
the judge in texas mr ponton i believe
you have a
filter turned on in the video settings
you might want to uh we're trying to
can you hear me judge i can hear you i
think it's a filter
it is and i don't know how to remove it
i've got my assistant here she's trying
to but
uh i'm prepared to go forward with it
that's i'm here live that's not i'm not
a cat
i can i can see that
i'm live here i'm not a cat
i'm donna friesen thanks for watching
take care of yourselves bye bye
you